[Música]
a opel está longe
sou professora e pesquisadora
e aí é de pesquisa nós fomos atrás de
saber o que será do chievo universitário
pensar sobre a verdadeiras porque quando
nós perguntamos pra eles
se ele saiu feliz com a saúde a educação
com a segurança e com a justiça quando
um deles é funcional e quando nós
perguntar mas o que você sabe que ela
sobre isso tá e aí que oferece of leon
uma esperança de você tem muitos
problemas e você não saber colón de que
maneira tenho esses problemas parecem
muito grande né menor abandonado é é um
digo é dependente química muito grande
mágica nós nem pensamos sobre isso eu
fui imaginar que tem pessoas que não
achavam estranho demais por exemplo
abordagem macaia na década de 70 ela é
professora de biologia ea entrada da
aula ela começou a observar que ela dá
ao desmatamento é tão grande que as
pessoas elas vão ter um colapso
ambiental e aí ela começou a ter contato
com as mães de aluguel do salão pelos 15
elas vão começar sem apontar não plantar
100 árvores frutíferas nos próximos dez
anos filho no período
ela começou a cortar
ela começou a conhecer ela começou a
mudar essas mães apontar essas mães
começaram a se sentir tão empoderadas
com uma causa da comida para os filhos
por pensar que dali dez anos
aquelas árvores elas poderiam gerar
comida dos filhos que isso gerou
a rede ante 51 milhões de reais e
chamado circulam com eles é bom acordar
e depois de o prêmio nobel grupo
distante stago mas ela começou como uma
professora de biologia e teve a
capacidade de olhar já um salva vidas e
é pensando nisso que falo a vocês que
pessoas foi agora tenho aprendido muito
grande disse não se lembrar a história
vai fazer o melhor
eu gosto de estar na história ele possa
fazer no bloco a partir de amanhã quando
eu penso isso eu tenho que entender que
para poder fazer isso pretende fazer um
processo de cidadania e de cidadania em
países como brasil é muito complicado
mas não é só o brasil falava da guerra
no mundo inteiro é muito complicado está
nos problemas que possam representar
aquela pesquisa que o carinho que vocês
podem perguntar o que desejava assim
olha o que você acha que a cidadania
eles dizem assim a exercício de direitos
e deveres pois é o conceito de cidadania
ao conselho foi capturado nos últimos
anos
na verdade ocorre a frio
e 80 e 90 as pessoas começaram a
perceber que nem o modelo socialista
comunista conseguiram resolver coisas
básicas como direitos humanos e
dignidade uma né muita gente passando
fome muita gente morrendo
desnecessariamente
e aí começou a acontecer alguns lucros
começar a recuperar a ideia da cidadania
o que ficou professor de cidadania ou é
direito a voto ou exercício de direito
de seguros
o problema com esse conselho
ele parece um conceito muito tranqüilo
bom a poderosa exercitar nosso golpe e
teoricamente nós temos direitos e
deveres que você pode em qualquer lugar
e exigir em fazer com que sejam roubados
o problema aqui hoje todo mundo fala de
cidadania e porque todo mundo fala de
cidadania e cidadania vivam conselho
capturado
então eu vou escutar sobre cidadania da
boca dos partidos políticos da montblanc
empresários da roupa da cidade da
sociedade civil da boca de líderes
religiosos
ninguém sabe ao certo mágico que é
cidadania
então essa cidadania ela virou um grande
monstro alguma coisa na calçada alguma
coisa que eu só consegui chegar
se um dia tivermos
é um dia conseguir desenvolver cultura o
suficiente ea idade complexo de vira
lata por brasileiros
a gente nunca acha que nós somos bons o
suficiente pra isso
quando você olha para a cidadania você
vê todo mundo estaria a pergunta que
fica é a cidadania é legal para o mundo
já que já tem problema porque o que é um
grande empresário certamente têm seus
direitos contemplados mais livros
ele tem moradia ele tem alimentação ele
tem saneamento básico mas certamente ele
não tem segurança
o petróleo poderá ajudar o outro dado
conflito social que nós vivemos hoje ele
tem que ter um carro e dar o que ele vai
para os condomínios fechados ou seja uma
parte dos seus direitos o direito civil
de mg nenhum e motivado
então a cidadania dele funciona pra pra
ele
a cidadania deste empresário não é a
mesma cidadania o morador de rua a quem
falta o básico do básico
essa cidadania não é igual eles querem
as mesmas coisas
então qual o problema
o conselho amplo cidadania que nós
também apresenta década de 80 o número é
o fato de que ela estará ancorada na
macro política e por que ela estava
curada na política ea cidadania pensada
só através da discussão dentro dos
grandes atrativos da discussão entre os
grandes projetos do governo
a discussão é das grandes ongs
internacionais ou das grandes
instituições internacionais
isso é um problema porque o que pra isso
acontecer
pressupõe-se que você tenha o nível de
empoderamento da população
como é que eu faço uma situação como o
brasil em que eu sou herdeiro de uma
política paternalista patrimonialista
paroquial onde todo mundo acha que se eu
voltar no vereador ele vai resolver o
problema então eu voto nele porque ele
vai conseguir telhado da minha casa
e essas pessoas elas não conseguem
entender porque não foi dada a ela a
possibilidade de aprender e por quatro
anos ela vai ser maculado
então nesse conceito eu tenho uma
fragmentação porque eu espero essa
pessoa a capacidade de moreira de
empoderamento que ela não consegue agora
ela não tem o que comer é uma coisa
simples
esse conceito é a capacidade de
articulação
ela não consegue denunciar traficantes a
rodela você acha que ela vai ter uma
capacidade de articulação para saber
quais são os seus direitos
com quatro faltas simples o sistema
representativo no brasil o programa
responde luca adicionar água fez um
trabalho maravilhoso e ela tem um
relatório incrível no brasil poucas
coisas que é de falar ela fala que a
pobreza deve impactar psicologicamente o
cobre sabe de antemão que ele vai ser
desrespeitada
ele sabe que é normal que se chegar
alguém primeiro serviço com uma ameaça
então por que eu vou pensar na
capacidade de luta e finalmente em
especial no brasil
eu adoro quando pega assim as pessoas
que chegam aqui próximo
aí os brasileiros eles são fofos
envolvidos
nossa como os brasileiros eles têm que
aprender na frança a inglaterra e as
pessoas tentam caso de trocar enfiar
goela abaixo do brasil o modelo
desenvolvimento da europa ou dos estados
unidos
o modelo cidadania que esteve lá
dá uma olhada nos novos números se você
olha pra história do brasil risos 18
anos
nós agiremos 2%
democrático como é o caso da liga
como é possível de cidadania nós como
súditos como tempo qualquer condição de
sucesso dito que quem tem de ver mas não
tem direito como é que eu aprenda a ter
direito de uma hora pra outra
uma canetada nénão país que acha que
você faz é porque você achou o papel com
cidadania diferente de modo mais
e aí ao longo da nossa história
nós criamos um balão embora porque o
brasil é o país do futuro e qual é a
língua
ora um dia nós vamos ter democracia
porque da unidade
eu tive é colônia de positivo na guia e
república democrática colocar não tem
democracia ditadura
então as pessoas ficavam assim ó um dia
venha a democracia quando a democracia
vive é a democracia por definição é o
governo de todos para todos e esse
governo de todos para todos vai esperar
que as pessoas se manifestam as pessoas
participem
e aí então eu vou ter cidadania no
brasil porque o brasil vai se
desenvolver porque hoje mas nesse
momento ele vai ser desenvolvido porque
aí quando as pessoas participar ela vai
ver que ela não precisa mais voltar a
usar os espaços públicos
elas vão aprender que não podem
estacionar em lugar proibido
mas são só dois minutinhos elas vão
aprender que elas podem é ficar a filha
não precisam furar a fila com tanta
pressa
então a gente criou na mentalidade
brasileira um dia
somente envolve a ética e muitas
definições de ética é o respeito para
com o outro e aí é complicado no brasil
porque quem ouve se o outro fosse como
eu estava resolvendo coisa legal mas o
que realmente é como o outro diferente
o outro ele é o causa contradição ele é
incompreensível ele não aceita tudo o
que eu digo
o outro é o meu vizinho é o 9 do nado
pelo posso mudar se aproveitar para
vencer politicamente correto mas sem
promessa é o ovo é o dependente químico
porque o dependente químico que está na
minha família merece compaixão mas
ficava na rua no brasil
bom e depois as pessoas no final de
semana na igreja os tempos espíritas têm
um título
só o outro menor sematur últimos tempos
o outro pensa diferente do paulista é o
coxinha tá bom tabela e nós somos
levados por essa cortina de fumaça a
acreditar que nós somos uma nação
rachada que nós somos um pouco que não
só
então é muito difícil técnica porque eu
só consigo técnica
eu falo de mim então a proposta pra
vocês é que a gente tenha é novas
práticas para novos tempos roberta marca
política da cidadania que está focado
nas grandes articulações dos partidos
políticos
isso não posso perder eu tenho que
continuar a estar envolvida com os
partidos eu tenho que continuar exigindo
que eles façam que perdei deles é
obrigação deles mas eu tenho que começar
a articular comigo eu aprendi isso não
escravos ante o dólar enquanto o pior
está a visão e os escravos eles
conseguiram que a rede de solidariedade
que aprender a suportar tal situação por
que não criar redes de solidariedade que
eles de interesse neles de
comprometimento hoje eu tenho um terreno
baldio na esquina da minha casa eu vou
esperar o do governo resolver não
consegue resolver a questão do sul
mas eu gosto de juntar à aliança e
transformar aquele terreno ao de uma
hora eu posso eu tenho problema dos
cachorros abandonados na rua porque eu
não posso votar todos eles na rua na
comunidade não pode cuidar daqueles
animais
isso é meio político é quando eu criei
eles de comprometimento rede de
solidariedade que de colaboração sem
depender das danças pessoas vejam que
estou
se eu verifico isso no cotidiano fica
muito mais fácil pra existe por isso
fácil porque revertemos partículas é
importante entender que nós estamos
todos conectados sofridos nós somos uma
sociedade machucada
nós vamos olhamos e nós não fazemos as
pequenas gentilezas
quantos de vocês aqui falar do bom dia
boa tarde pessoal estava dando suporte
não precisa mais ninguém faz isso e é
tão legal isso enquanto você vai ao
supermercado agradecer a essa moça
assustada com a palavra não existe mais
bom dia boa tarde por favor das pequenas
gentilezas
para isso ele fala 90 do tempo seria
emocional da ausência de comprometimento
disse o pesquisador aí eu tenho pesquise
pj pesquisa sobre ribeirão preto
e aí eu perguntamos para vocês e 600
pessoas no peró os mais variados lucros
que poderá pedir o que elas queriam a
cidade sentiu falta na cidade
e aí foi um caos porque começou a
aparecer assim falta de ética na cidade
é dito a respeito da ação cidadã na ilha
mas começou a parecer muito a palavra
amor à minha formação é profundamente a
caneta objetivo é possível haver alguma
dificuldade na rua três vezes e aí
quando ele estava a três vezes o pessoal
agora chega nessa troca
se você gosta da tua
se você gosta da cidade
a casa já deve ter ouvido falar da
janela quebrada
eu gosto eu tenho relação de pertença eu
vou cuidar
e aí gera gentileza e é muito
interessante porque as pessoas mais
ansiosas sensacionais iosa gentileza
gera bem-estar
toda vez que você cuida do ovo que você
apoia o outro isso gera em você uma
quantidade imensa de um ano de bem estar
e melhor embora aquele chocolate então
praticar gentileza é legal porque fazem
a minha proposta é essa que a cidadania
é um ato de gentileza
a vontade não tem o outro por nós
por mim eu ouvi é um ato de vontade
podem idéia pra gente cidadania no
sealand porque é importante trabalhar no
site
nós estamos destruídas
nós mal catão nosso verão nós poluímos
na mesma proporção que nós fazemos isso
nós geramos cada vez mais tentativas de
vida hoje em dia as pessoas morre
a proposta é aluguer daquela ética é
cuidar é respeitar os outros
a minha proposta é a ética como
compaixão
até o século 20 era muito importante ter
uma inteligência
guerreira racional proativo por fácil
aconteceram mesmo nas sensações e
sentimentos
eu não consigo mais um sério motivo de
termos da razão mas tem que ter a
inteligência da compaixão a inteligência
sentido outros como eu faço isso
aprendendo a cuidar abandonando o bahia
perde nas relações
tenho uma amiga que deu à altura podia
ela disse assim eu falava e nós
precisamos parar de novo como uma
oportunidade
não é uma oportunidade de negócio
vamos abandonar ganha perde e ganha
ganha raízes nas relações internacionais
do que na minha rua porque não né tv
digital respeito o acolhimento ea
hospitalidade eles é isso a gente tem
uma chance no contrato não é mole ou
aprendendo a cuidar oferecendo a
proposta é simples
daça